Hello and
welcome
everyone to the Active Inference Lab.
This is the model stream
number 2.1 on April 16th.
20, 21.
And today is going to be an awesome
model stream.
We're just going to briefly go around
and introduce ourselves
and then I'll just mention
how the session will be run today,
and then we'll pass it
to Noor for presentation.
So I'm Daniel and I'm
a post-doctoral researcher in California.
I'll pass to Philip.
I am currently a student
at Oxford in my second year.
And yeah, I guess this is a work
I did kind of force my Ph.D.
once. I'd know.
And I'm currently focusing on data
efficiency within specifically
reinforcement learning.
But I guess on that topic,
like the knowledge of active inference
is obviously useful
for approaching such research.
And or
I I'm
I'm a third year patient
in a theoretical neurobiology group
at the Welcome Center for Human
Imaging at UCL.
So that's University College London.
So my Ph.D., supervised by calls
focused on these ideas
pertaining to adaptation, one of which
I'll be focusing on today, which is
behavioral adaptation and station
environments using active inference.
So thank you. Awesome.
Thanks both for joining
and for this presentation.
We're going to be hearing a who knows
how long a presentation from Noor
and then I'm going to be
compiling questions from the chat.
So please
just type questions as they come to you
and then we'll address them at the end.
So thanks again.
And Noor, please take it away.
Perfect. Thank you.
So today I'll be presenting
some what that I did in collaboration
with Philip, who you've just had
from the most part uncle for.
So it's titled Accident Friends
Demystified.
And compared
Okay.
Okay. Perfect.
So the presentation
structured as follows.
Can you show some screens?
I think I was sharing it. Was it?
You're not able to see it.
I'm not seeing it.
Could you just share it?
Yeah, sure.
And technology, I tell you.
There we go. And I'll crop it.
So go for it. Thanks. And perfect.
Thank you.
So the presentation
structured as follows.
That's our briefly motivate the program
setting and provide details
of a particular active inference
instantiation under consideration
today, which is the discrete state space
setting.
And the second half of the presentation
is going to be focused
on some particular examples, comparing
that to the inference formulation
with reinforcement learning, specifically
Q learning and Bayesian
model based algorithm.
And then what I'm going to do is provide
some face validity of particular aspects
of why you would want
to even use active inference
Okay.
And so what is active inference
and is a first principle account
of how biological or artificial agents
may operate in dynamic
non stationary settings?
It stipulates that these agents,
in order to maintain homeostasis, reside
in attraction states that minimize
their entropy or their surprise.
So if you take this particular example
that we're seeing of this pass middle
hungry agent, I think the fridge,
the way it would work is
you would need to
why would you open a French fry?
So you want to make a particular choice
between eating at home or outside.
And in order to do that,
you have to decide
what is the optimal action
that would allow you to resolve your own
uncertainty
about the current stage of the set.
So and that would help you then decide
whether you want to cook at home
or you want to walk to the restaurant.
And in this particular instance,
this has led to the agent
opening the fridge to check
whether it even has food at home.
And what's nice about active inference
is that it allows you
to think about these problem settings
in a more formal way
by specifying that optimal behavior
is determined
by evaluating the evidence that is,
the sensory input under the agents
gentle model of observations
that it is being exposed to.
And in this particular presentation,
what we'll do is focus on
just the process theory
that underwrites active inference
and not talk through the biological
or the neural plausibility
of the active inference
message passing game.
But to properly motivate
why we would want to even use
active inference in comparison to generic
reinforcement learning algorithms.
We need to first start off with this
understanding that with an active
inference, this is commitment
to a pure belief base scheme,
which means that reward functions
are not always
necessarily unnecessary
because any policy that you would have
has a epistemic value,
even in the absence of preferences
Additionally, active inference agents can
also learn their own reward functions.
And this helps the agent describe
the type of behavioral that it expects
to see itself, as opposed to something
that you would get from the environment.
And these two particular points
are important in contrast
to reinforcement learning,
because understanding RL settings,
the reward function would define
how the agent interacts or behaves
within a particular environment. Setting.
But defining that reward
function in the first place
is quite difficult because it assumes
that there is a specific signal
being given from the environment
that can be unanimously good
or bad for the agent,
which wouldn't necessarily hold true
in a real setting where these environment
signals can change
depending on the setting, for example.
Eating ice cream is not always
going to be rewarding, if you will.
And it might make you less
And that's why constructing
these reward functions in the first place
is extremely difficult.
And if you're not constructing them
in the appropriate way,
even with a natural setting,
it can result in suboptimal behavior
for your agents.
An activity, for instance,
where you good in the sense
because we are actually replacing
or bypassing the traditional reward
function that you would have
in the RL setting with prior beliefs
about bad outcomes that are sort of
desired states of the face
that you want to see yourself being.
And this becomes important in settings
where there's no reward
or this imprecise understanding
of a reward or preference
setting should look like.
And that in this scenario,
within the sum of natural inference,
discrete state formulation,
what we can do is not empirical prior
distribution
over these preferred outcomes.
And intrinsic as
the internal reward
function of that agent.
And this sort of brings me
to like the first distinct
conceptualization between oral
setting and active inference,
because within active inference,
rewards are nothing distinct.
They are just a standard observation
that the agent is getting
from the environment, whereas in our role
they're quite necessary to
have appropriate action
that the agent is going to that
The second point we want to make.
So we wanted to make was that active
inference provides a principal account
of epistemic exploration and intrinsic
motivation as minimizing uncertainty.
And again, within the oral setting,
this is quite crucial because the whole
premise of like lots of new algorithms
that we see in our in our role
is to try and find the right tradeoff
for the balance between exploration
and exploration.
So what are the rights of actions
that the agent should make
at a given point in time?
Should it carry on choosing
all the different ice cream flavors
that it's been never been exposed
to, like mustard, et cetera?
Or should it always use the oh, sorry,
always have the same ice cream flavor
that's been exposed in the past
that it really likes it
because I'm Caucasian on a tether
for instance.
So this is it's an outstanding problem
with an oral and under a patient
framework, active inference deals with it
naturally.
Using the expected free energy formulation that I'll come to in a moment.
And the last bit
that you can see within the active
inference framework is that it
naturally accounts for uncertainty
as part of the belief updating process.
Okay.
So now that's sort of laid out
the three things that that's super
interesting about the active inference
scheme in comparison to IRL.
I'm going to provide some intuitions
as to why
you can assert
some motivations
as to why we can even formulate
that of inference formulation
the way we do
OK, so I'm
sorry, I just realized I like skipped
ahead.
Sorry.
Great presentation. Yep.
Thank you so much.
And let me just scroll down to
okay.
So I previously stated that within
active inference,
it stipulates that agents are maintaining
their hemostasis
by residing in attracting states
that minimize surprise.
So you must have been thinking
what is surprise?
Well, how we define surprise
as a negative low probability of outcomes
And for this, we introduce
one run variable, which is that
corresponds to a particular outcome
that's received by an agent.
And this exists within a finite set of
all possible outcomes, and that's here.
So first equation that we have
just formally states that out
and here denotes the probability
distribution over outcomes
And so in active inference,
the way the agent will actually minimize
the surprise quantity that we just walk
through is by maintaining
a gentle model throughout.
And this is important
because at any given point in time,
the agent wouldn't necessarily
have access to the true measurements
of the current state of the world.
So in this particular graphic
that you see here,
you've got the environment
and the agent interacting
with the environment in the way
it's being exposed to the sensory signal,
but it doesn't know what the outcome was
generated by.
So many perceive itself and the world
around it through only the eye.
And needs to make inferences
about what type of states or
the true causes were responsible
for the particular sensory
input that is being exposed to.
And this is why
an act
of inference when we form the problem,
we formulate as a party observe
what make up decision process.
Because in this way
we are able to formulate a gentle model
that defines this internal distribution
over the internal states
that the agent would use
in order to impact the outcome
so they doesn't have access
to the true state.
But it can make hypotheses or beliefs
about the states that could have given
rise to a particular sense outcome space
that it's being exposed to.
And using this, the agent
will make inferences about the true state
using a process of reverse mapping,
specifically Bayesian model inversion.
And to make this a little bit
more concrete, what you can do
is think about the hidden states
as locations or color.
For example, the observation states
that the agent would be exposed to
would be for example, that the velocity
of the movement or a particular reward
or like a happy face
that they're being exposed to
Okay.
So if we were to think about this
in this example formally,
so what is the to model?
So as we
described before, a gentle model
is a partially observable MDP.
And within this active inference
formulation, which rests on a simplified
setting that we're considering here
where we only have to run the variables.
The first one is that we've discussed.
And the second one is S where S denotes
a random variable representing hidden
or latent states exists within a finite
set of all possible hidden states,
which is denoted by capital S here.
And this join probability
that we get over
O and S can be factored
into the likelihood function which is
given s.
And then you have the prior either
the internal states, which is P. S.
So this gives you a very nice formulation
that we are going to use
in these next couple of slides.
I just wanted to ask, are you able to see
my mouse when I highlight or when I.
Or is that not that.
I can see it? Yes.
In a perfect
so we know that for an agent to minimize
that surprise,
we would need to marginalize out
all the possible hidden states that
could have led to a different outcome.
And this can be achieved by using
the factorization that I just mentioned,
the likelihood of the problem.
But the the problem is that
this is not a trivial task because
the dimensionality of the hidden states
can be extremely large.
And if you're considering
additional random variables, though,
we're going to introduce in a bit.
This becomes even more problematic.
And that's why we use
another quantity, a variation
or approximation of this quantity,
which is more tractable and allows us
to estimate the quantities of interest
And so so this will
be a natural step
to talk about the variation for energy,
which is this very general approximation
of the quantity of interest.
So what is variation for energy?
So variation for energy is defined
as the upper bound one surprise
to the first definition.
Sorry, first definition
that we considered
as derived using Jensen's
inequality is commonly known
as negative evidence
bound in the variation in literature.
So we get this from the equation for that
we just saw by introducing
negative lock on both sides
and then multiplying
this term by one,
which is essentially Q of S.
So we're assuming that Q
if S cannot be equal to zero.
And with that
we then apply Jensen's inequality
and we move the log inside the function
and we end up with our expectation
with respect to Cube.
As for the joint over the approximate
or the
on quantity of interest here.
And then we take the negative inside
and looking around and we get our
first nice
quantity of interest here
where we get the balance
that we're interested in
in terms of scale between the approximate
and the joint that we have
So to make this a little bit
more concrete, what we can do
now is to further manipulate
the variation for energy summons
into the scale between the approximate
and the true posterior.
Minus the log evidence that we
the model evidence that we had
and we can rearrange the last equation
to really hone in on the connection
between surprises.
Variational Free Energy.
So if you remember
that Cal is a divergence,
which means that it cannot be
less than zero, so is always strictly
greater than or equal to zero,
which means that when our approximate
is equal to the true posterior,
we end up with the variation free energy,
equal to the model evidence,
which means that minimizing
free energy is essentially equivalent
to maximizing the gentle model evidence.
OK, And
we can rewrite the previous equation
that we had equation ten
to express the variation
for energy as a function of plus
to replace in multiple different forms.
So I'm just going to focus on Equation
12 here, which is the complexity
minus accuracy.
So this is a tradeoff
that's normally used within
the papers
that essentially says the complexity
or complexity cost is essentially
your tail between your approximate cis
s given pi with respect
to your p of s given
pi and here PI is just your policies
and these can be regardless of hypothesis
of how the agent is going to act.
But I'll come back
to what policies really entail.
But for now, just consider them as a term
that allows us to condition
the free energy on a sequence
of trajectories of interest.
And the second term that we have
is the log probability of a given s.
So the likelihood
with a
with respect to the key of s
that gives you the accuracy.
So a simple way to think about it
is that this is just
how accurate the model is
and this is some regularization time.
That's a penalty term to make sure
that it's not diverging too far away
from our initial priors. OK.
So this particular quantity variation
for energy.
Any questions at this point
about the potential for energy
Not yet. Thank you. Yep.
OK, so the variation for energy
is giving us this way of perceiving
the environment and address is one part
of the active inference formulation
which is making inferences
about getting wild
that the agent is interacting
with at a given point in time.
However, we have not actually accounted
for the active part,
whereas, like this particular agent that
we have under the active in principle
relation can take series of actions
or interact with the environment
in such a way that it affects
that environment in the future.
So to motivate this a little bit further,
what we can think about
is that not only do we want to minimize
operational free energy,
we also want to minimize
the quantity called expected for energy,
which depends on anticipated observations
about the future in the future
or about the future
and minimization of this particular times
allows the agent to influence the future
by taking particular actions
in the present which are selected
from a set of policies.
So I mentioned policies a few times now.
So what are they?
So policies can be defined
as a sequence of actions, a timetable
that enable an agent to transition
between hidden states.
And here is essentially
a sequence of trajectories up
to a particular horizon cap,
which is considering the total number
of time steps that you are considering
in a particular setup.
And for us to properly define policy,
we need to introduce
two additional random variables.
So the first one is an action
that's conditional on Tao,
which is denoted by Utah here.
And this exists within a finite set
of all possible actions
that the agents can take
And the second random variable
that we introduce is
policy,
which is the PI that we've discussed.
And this exists within a finite set
of all possible policies
or sequence of actions in a sense of like
the sequential policy optimization
that we're interested in here.
So to make it a little bit more concrete
perhaps the random variable
can be decomposed
into a series of actions
over a particular time and time
horizon. Tao.
So you want you to when going up to Utah
to see action from action
at times, one at a time we do and so on.
And the link is explicit
when you consider that
if you consider policy
at a particular time point.
So Tao then the action that
you get would be that action.
OK, cool.
And so I also wanted to highlight
that this definition of policy
is actually quite different to
or distinct to how it's considered in RL,
which is when they say policy
to mean state action policies.
So as I just mentioned,
an act of inference, a policy is simply
a sequence of choices for actions, a time
that is a sequential policy.
And this is different
to a state action policy in reinforcement
learning,
which is mapping of states to actions.
So your RL policy,
which takes into account
the action of the state,
is probability of your action
given the state
and under a common formulation
the definition of action,
a sorry definition of policies
and oral and active inference
become exactly the same when we consider
the setting where Tao is equal to one
so you're only considering one step ahead
OK, so
I'm going to move a little bit
and consider the constant of interest,
the expense of energy which is to
how do we even derive it?
So in order to derive that,
we first need to extend the variation
for energy definition that we had before.
So a few slides ago
and now make it dependent about time.
So towel and policy.
And what we're doing
essentially is taking that same equation
and just decomposing it for previous,
so previous and current
time step under a particular policy
so that what
this is why we have the conditioning
and then we're decomposing it
in a specific way in equation 15
and then writing out the matrix
formulation in equation 16
so we can come back to this 30 questions.
But the key thing
to take away from the slides is that now
we're including
a functional dependency in time
for the variation for energy
and this is allowing us to now
move to the expected year
for energy formulation.
But the key thing to note here is
that we're only considering time points
the previous time point and the present,
not the future
until
so using the free energy equation for
we can derive the expected free energy
and what is the expected
free energy then.
So expect to free energy
is the free energy function of future
trajectories and it effectively rallies
the evidence for a plausible policies
based on outcomes
that have not been observed yet.
So that's the key thing.
So you're making inferences
about the pulse,
the set of features or directories
that you have observed,
and there's a two restricts
that are introduced here
in order to get to the G formulation
that we see in Equation 70.
The first
one is to include beliefs
about future outcomes in the expectation.
That is where supplementing excitation
under the approximate posterior
with the likelihood here
which results
in a predictive distribution given
by these two terms here
and the second one is
that we're implicitly
or explicitly conditional
on the joint probabilities of states
and observations in the gentle model
or in the gentle model dependent
on the desired state of affairs,
as opposed to a particular policy now.
So this constrains the type
of preferences that the agent would have.
And what's helpful with these two moves
that we're making is that
we can now evaluate this quantity
before actually having the observations.
And the second one
is that the minimization of GEE
would actually encourage polity policies
to be consistent
with the desired state of affairs
that the agent expects itself to be in.
And I'm just going to briefly mention
that this is not the only way
to derive expected for energy.
And there's been some work
that's looked at other formulations,
including what I call
the formulation of
expected free energy can be decomposed
into different structures.
So if anyone's interested in that,
we can go through it
later on.
But this free, I expect you for energy
that I just introduced me
to compose in certain ways.
So equation 20
and 21 and two different decompositions
the first one being that the stomach
and the extrinsic value trade
and the second one being the expected
cost and ambiguity time
so if we just consider
the extent of the first equation,
we can say that if we're minimizing
this equation then we're capturing
this imperative to maximize
the information gain that you would have
from observing the environment
about particular hidden states
while maximizing the expected value
which is scored by the low preferences
or the extrinsic value here.
So this particular formulation
actually gives us a very clear tradeoff
between the
the first component, which
is the epistemic value that promotes
curious behavior.
So that's what you want with exploration
encouraged as the agent seeks out
these new states that minimize
uncertainty about the environment.
And the latter bit is more pragmatic
and it encourages exploitative behavior
through this understanding
of the type of policies
that the agent would prefer to reach.
In other words, like this expected
free energy formulation
that we've seen in Equation
20 is essentially treating exploration
and exploitation as two different ways
of tackling the same problem.
So minimizing uncertainty
that I mentioned at the start
of the presentation
table.
We can also think about the second
equation here,
which is just offering us
an alternative perspective on
if we expect to find you,
which is an agent who wishes to minimize
the ambiguity
and the degree to which outcomes
under a particular policy
deviate from prior preferences.
Thus, ambiguity here is expectation
of the conditional entropy
or the uncertainty about outcomes
under the current policy.
In this particular setting,
low entropy would suggest the outcomes
are quite salient and uniquely
informative about the states.
So for example,
the visual cues that you might see
if the room is actually pretty tough in
comparison to is quite dark,
you're not going to encounter
anything important from that.
In addition,
you might pursue policy
dependent outcomes
that resemble is preferred outcomes
so that's the denoted by C here.
And this is achieved
when the or divergence
between the predicted
and the preferred outcomes is minimized.
By a particular policy set.
And these beliefs about the future
outcomes equip
the agent with goal directed behavior,
which is one of the,
I guess the instances
that is very important
in active inference
OK, so
once we have expected your fantasy,
we can derive the the policies.
So and this is realized
by deriving the probability of any policy
by applying a soft max function
over the expected for energy.
And this sort of illustrates the self
evidencing behavior of active inference
because any sort of policy
or action sequence that results in lower
expected free energy are more likely.
And intuitively this would
make sense because
the X factor for energy
is sort of encapsulating
all the types of things
that you want to include
or consider
when you're interacting with the well.
So you want to explore,
you want to exploit,
but you want to have a balance of that.
And then when you're selecting
your policy,
it's just a matter of determining
the set of actions
which get you closest
to this particular goal.
And this can be defined
by an attractive search that is defined
by you see
matrix that we described before.
And if you don't have that,
then it's just random exploration
that you would get.
Sometimes you can also include
a temperature parameter beta here.
And by having a hyper prime on this,
you introduce
additional complexity customs
and I expect you for energy formulation
which allows you to account
for how flat or
how confident
or precise you want your preferences
to be over
the policy space.
But the key thing to note is that
for sake of simplicity,
I'm not going to go through a lot of the
the details
about how these are optimized.
But you can do that
in multiple different ways.
For example, in active inference,
we can optimize expectation
about the hidden states of interests,
the policies, the precision
through inference, and then we can also
optimize the model parameters through
through the planning procedures involved.
But those sort of differ
depending on the setup.
You're looking at for example,
if you're using very full face,
you would just iterate this.
These functions are objective functions
until convergence or an act of inference,
you do a gradient descent to find
the sufficient statistics of interest.
Again, this depends on exactly which
formulation and setup you're looking at.
But the key
thing to note here is that there's three
particular aspects to the active
inference algorithm that are useful
and can be taken from this particular
framework and apply to other settings.
So I'm just going to reiterate
summarize them briefly.
So we first have the to model
that's crucial so in order for an agent
to interact and minimize a surprise,
it needs a gentleman of the world.
And that's described as simply I'm
not I'm
not including any of the model parameters
here, but you can have your outcomes,
your states and your policies.
And this these are decomposed into.
Yes, sorry,
there's an error with the brackets here,
but these are decomposed into your prior
your likelihood
of your transition function.
And then you set once you have this done
to model the objective,
the agent is to set the model
to sample observations
to reduce the price, and that is through
variation, energy optimization.
So this particular tradeoff
that we have between the complexity
and the accuracy cost.
And then the second sorry,
the last part of this algorithm
is to plan to select actions
that minimize uncertainty,
that that is the expected strategy.
And the way you do
that is by having a soft max over that
this g negative of G, the quantity
we have here
and then sampling for that in order
to select the next best, best action.
OK, so that's a
quick and deep dove into a massive amount
of active inference literature.
I just wanted to highlight
that those are the three core ingredients
that if you are interested
in implementing
these algorithms yourself.
OK, so now I'm just going to switch gears
a little bit
and walk through the comparisons
with reinforcement learning.
So in our what we considered
a modified version
of the Open
Jim's Frozen Lake environment.
So Frozen Lake has a grid like structure
with four distinct catches.
It has a starting point,
which is s so we can see it.
Yes, apologies,
but it's super tiny S's here
and you've got the frozen surface,
which is F.
So again, I don't think I can differentiate because I'm just moving my mouse.
I'm zooming in, they can see it.
I get perfect.
So you've got the frozen s
and then you've got the hole.
And then lastly, you have the goal.
So you have with a first base located
an oil patches in this particular
setup are safe, except for a hole
where if the agent goes to H,
it gets a negative reward,
the agent starts each episode
at the first position,
which is the starting position.
And from there
it needs to reach the first location in
in the
in the least amount of steps possible.
And the way it can do
that is by performing
four different types of actions
either going left, right down or up
and the agent is allowed to carry
on moving through the frozen lake
with multiple revisit.
So settings can go back to the starting
position.
Having gone in other places
but each episode will end
when either
it reaches the hole or the goal location.
And these locations
differ depending on the set up
that we have in our simulations.
So in one set up, the position of
the hole is eight and the goal is six.
And another set up
the position of the hole is six and
the goal is eight.
And the objective is,
as I said, to reach the goal and it's few
steps as possible while avoiding the hole
because that would end the episode.
If it reaches the goal,
it gets the positive reward.
100 and negative otherwise.
The key thing to note here
is that the scoring metric actually
allows us some way to compare the active
inference algorithms to a reinforcement
learning algorithms
but it is not really important
for the active inference algorithm to
have the reward function as a get go
because it can still move around using
just the information gain time.
So not having the extrinsic value
component.
And that's quite interesting
because we'll see the ramifications
of that in our simulations
for this particular set up.
We limit to the maximum number of time
steps for each episode
to 15 OK,
so what I'm going to do
is first talk through the gentle model
that we use for the active inference
formulation.
So here what you're seeing on
the slide is a graphical
representation of the active inference
gentle model.
So this model contains
four action states.
So right down up to the left
and these control
the ability to transition
between
hidden states in the case, in fact.
So for example,
if you are in a position where
and you take the action right,
then you end up in position two
or if you are in location five
and you take the other action
you will end up in position two as well.
In this
particular setting, both positions
six and eight are absolving states
because if you remember,
once the agent goes to that location,
they're not able to move out.
So that's when the episode ends.
And if an agent makes an improper move
in this particular case, for example,
if it tries to go from position
one to left
and with a state in that location,
it won't move
in this particular gentle model.
So I'm just looking
at the hidden states now.
We have a to transfer product
between the two factors.
So we have location and context here.
The context cannot be changed
by the agent that we have
because this is something that's
determined by the environment in which
this determines
what are the going to hold locations are,
whereas the location is something
that the agent has control over.
And that's why
we have the action states over this.
So with
the context, we have two contexts.
The first one is where the goal is in
your location eight
and the is in the patient.
Six And the second context
is where the goal is application six
and the hole is in the case eight
at each time point,
the agent will observe two outcomes.
One would be its own position
in this particular maze.
And the second would be the school
that the agent would get
the likelihood for.
The great position is entirely determined
by the location of the agent
and the school is determined by
both the location of the context in play.
So if the agent is in location six
and eight is in context to,
then I will receive a positive reward.
Otherwise it will receive a negative or
neutral reward depending on where it is
based
on trying to make that comparison
with reinforcement learning.
What we're doing here
is we are introducing
price preferences
where the agent has plus school
for positive reward, negative for school,
sorry, minus
false negative reward and otherwise.
And at the first stage it expects itself
to be in the first location
so we compared this particular
Gem's model
and the active inference agent
to two reinforcement learning algorithms.
So the first one was the Q learning
using epsilon greedy exploration.
And the second one was the Bayesian
model based reinforcement
learning algorithm
using standard sports and sampling
and some sum sampling is appropriate
procedure higher because it entails
the optimization of few objectives,
reward maximization and information gain
and this is achieved
by having this distribution
over a particular function
that we promote twice by a prior,
just by having a prior distribution
over it that we sample from
K so for
the 22 learning algorithms,
we have to explain greedy parameters.
So one where it's fixed exploration
set to 0.1, and then another one
where we have the king exploration
that starts from one and decays
down to zero
so first we assessed this
how the agents interacted
in a stationary setting where the reward
was not changing
such that the goal location was always at
six and the whole location was
always at eight.
And then we evaluate
the performance of the agents.
The key thing to take away from here
is that both the Bayesian general
and the active inference agents
are able to quickly learn
whether reward location is
and just maximize it out.
And this is this is performance
is consistent, denoted by the body
type confidence problems
that we see in comparison.
The Q learning agents are
so for the one where we have
six exploration, it's fairly
fairly good and is able to learn
where the reward is allocated.
But there is some deviation generated by
that 10% of selected more random action,
whereas the
Q learning where we have
Epsilon is equal to 1280.
The performance isn't the greatest.
And for the No model, the active
inference where there is no reward here,
the agent randomly goes to the hole
and randomly goes
to the goal 50% of the time.
But the key thing to note
is that apart from the non model,
all the models are doing fairly
well and seem
to be performing OK
within this stationary setting.
So the next thing.
Nor can I just make a point
about these experiment as well
just because they also do bear away
slightly from the traditional light,
which is yeah, great.
So basically what usually happens is
you kind of have
this ambiguous between like training time
and test time performance.
And you usually especially in a
Q learning, like you just take
the max over the cue function.
We have a policy
that tries to do like some search
over the cue function
and takes that max like given a state.
But that's
kind of an artificial distinction,
which is like obviously as you're
acquiring data, you're making mistakes
in the environment, you're interacting
with the real environment.
So in order
to kind of make that fair comparison
between here and active inference
where you don't really have
this distinction
between like training time and test
time, it's all just interaction.
The that's the reason
why the Q learning agent, especially when
Epsilon is fixed to say 0.1
never achieves the optimal policy simply
because we're also with 0.1 probability
taking a random action.
So we're not making this distinction
like you sometimes would with normal rule
between train and test.
Like we're saying, train
and test some of the same thing.
So however
you're choosing to interact with
the world is how you should be assessed.
So that's that's why
I'm actually looking at this, because
you might be like, hang on, my why isn't.
Q letting solving this?
But yeah, that's just a clear
something up if a more familiar
with, say, somebody like
de pro experimental procedure
perfect.
Thank you.
OK, and
then just following on from that,
so we change the environment a little bit
to make it a little bit more difficult
to see whether the Bayesian
and the active inference agents
might struggle when we stopped
having the reward occasion change
after every few episodes.
So specifically we swapped the goal
and the whole location at
a time point 21 a time, 120,
141, 251 and 451.
So you can see that in these figures
where the line, the gray lines are shown
that these points,
they're all location flipped.
So like the stationary setting
for the first 20 trials
or the agents seem to be doing
as you would expect for both the Bayesian
RL and the action
inference agents are doing fairly.
OK, the Q landing with the fixed
explorations set
to 0.1 is doing fairly
OK as we saw before and the Q learning
with the decay exploration is
is doing as it was doing before.
But when you flip it around such
that the goal locations change,
what you notice is that with the Bayesian
RL agent, the
the amount of reward or the score
it gets is quite low.
And then we see a phase
where it then transitions and becomes
to the optimal policy again in comparison
to the active inference agent
where it instantly after the first trial
of doing the incorrect is able
to switch over to the active
and sorry the appropriate policy.
And the reason for that is for these oral
settings where we're considering Yes.
And learning problem.
You need to first do professor
learning of where the reward location is
and then the new reward location.
So you're seeing that for.
Q learning about the different epsilon
greedy dramatizations
and also for the patient zero.
And we're seeing that consistently
whereas with the active inference agent,
because we're treating it
as a timing inference problem
where the plots two years from the
previous date are moved over to the prize
and we do the rest prize,
the agent is able to instantly
realize that the current policy
that was following the less time step
is an appropriate and switches its policy
to the next to the, the other one.
Again,
the non model as expected
doesn't really do much because it's
just exploring doesn't really count where
the reward or the whole location are.
OK, and so do you want to add something
to this or.
No, I think the same point applies
to this one.
Yep, definitely. OK,
so just to wrap up
with these two comparisons and
with the non well the stationary setting,
all types of agents
and including the patient oral
and the Q letting would be reasonable
frameworks. Yes.
Whereas with the with a non state
forensic
stochastic
setting having an active inference
agents might be appropriate way
of having change in dynamics.
The key caveat with that
is that you can introduce
a lot more additional complexity
into the patient RL or the Q learning
or the RL framework in general
to allow for way to handle uncertainty,
but it wouldn't be
a natural way of adding it.
You would have to sort of
augment the
function or the algorithm
in particular ways to justify
OK, so,
so once we have done this comparison,
we were interested in,
why would you even want to use
active and friends
when you don't have
an understanding about the world or
you don't have sort of a preference over
the type of things that could be done?
Because as we saw the active inference
model the model is just exploring.
It's not really doing much.
And that's brings us to
one of the initial points that introduce
to start the presentation, which is that
within an active inference line,
what we don't really care about having
a reward function that we can learn.
We can learn that based on
some interaction with the environment and
so for that
what we did was we carried out
a few different simulations
to see how the active inference agents
can select different types
of policies
in the absence of prior preferences.
And for this, we
we did three different experiments
where we allowed either or the likelihood
and all the outcome preferences
to be large over time.
And so how the agent interacted
when this learning over
the different preferences took place
and the way we did
it was using the conjugate models where
because these are discrete state models
we have categorical distributions
over our model parameters
and we're introducing dirichlet
distributions on top as our hyper price.
And that is a type of prize
we can go into the details of this
if anyone has any questions.
But just for simplicity,
just assume that all the Jewish life
distributions were set to set
completely flat and the agents were all
given an opportunity to land
based on different interactions they had.
So the first experiment,
like the simulations that we ran,
were to understand how the agent reduces
uncertainty about the environment
that is interaction.
So if it doesn't know that the, the, the,
the frozen lake, how would it interact
or explore that lake?
And what we see is that
in this particular instance,
the agent was just interested
in exploring and didn't
particularly care about the
where the goal or the whole location was.
And this is highlighted in a series
of different
exploration trajectories that we see.
So the first one was
where the agent falls in the hole,
and then another one where it goes around
and ends up at the second.
And in the second episode
at the goal location.
And then somewhere it just ends
the episode by just going back and forth.
So this is just for exploration,
nothing more here.
The next
set of analysis or simulations
that we ran was to see what would happen
if the agent knew about the world
but had no
preferences of the type of outcomes
they expected itself to be in.
And for this, we ran multiple different
simulations and so that in the absence of
any sort
of preferences,
the hole could actually become
really attractive
if it's encountered first.
So we see that in the first figure
that the agent learns
to prefer to hide in holes.
And in the second type of trial,
that we saw
was where the agent
exhibited the preference
to actually go to the goal location.
So this is entirely dependent
on the incentive option
or the type of stimulus
that the agent is exposed to initially
that determines the type of preferences
it would like to have OK.
And then the last set of simulations
that we ran was just to check
what would happen
when we interacted with the epistemic
to such a result, uncertainty
about the environment that the agent
was interacting with,
specifically the likelihood mapping
between the outcomes given the states
and the uncertainty
about the desired state of affairs
that the agent expected herself to be in.
And what we saw was that if we allowed
a sufficient number of cons to cost
the agent in this particular setting land
to prefer to ride us or hide in holes
after X number of episodes.
But it had a very distinct
preference over
the type of outcomes it expected itself
to be depending on the particular
trajectory as a particular time point.
And so that brings me
to the last simulation.
So I'm just going to wrap up
which is in active inference,
I saw over presentation
what saying it's a particular algorithm
that gives us very nice things
to consider when we're
operating in Bayesian or belief
based setting, which is firstly
the principle account of epistemic
exploration and intrinsic motivation
that we get from the particular
X free energy decomposition
that we went through.
The second thing that I wanted to
highlight was that
under an active inference setting,
we don't have to explicitly specify
a reward function,
which we saw in the last
the second set of simulations
where the agent can also
learn its own reward and prefer to become
something that is quite counterintuitive
from a RL setting
where the signal from environment
to saying something is bad,
but the agents in tandem
occupations of preference allow it to
then do something that's quite at odds
with what the environment is expecting it
to do.
And lastly,
because of this belief, Bayesian
setting uncertainty
is a natural part of the beliefs.
Updating
so within the stationary settings, active
inference agents perform
as well as reinforcement learning agents.
However, enunciation settings
that perform due to their ability
to carry out this planning inference
and that's I think that holds.
This is not a conclusive statement,
but is is a
nice way to start thinking about how
if you're scaling up
active inference agents to interact
on the same type of environments
as reinforcement learning agents,
that might be a little bit hard
to resolve
because there is some nonspeech
narrative,
some weird fluctuations
happening in the assignment,
and that's an inference agents
could potentially perform quite nicely
if we have this planning as an incentive
and that brings me
to the end of the presentation.
So I just want to thank everyone
who was involved with this work.
So I call Tom and Phil
and everyone who's helped me
think through these interesting ideas
that I presented.
So and everyone also for listening.
Thank you.
Awesome talk.
So you can maybe unshared
and we can ask a few questions
and if anyone who's watching
live would like to ask questions, there
more than welcome.
So maybe I'll start with just
a general point that it was awesome
to see how clearly you differentiated
between the reinforcement learning
and the active inference paradigm.
And just one question I had was
you mentioned that in the case of a time
step of one, a time horizon of one,
there was like an equivalence between
the reinforcement learning approach
and the active inference approach.
Now people are using reinforcement
learning to do
planning for the future
amidst uncertainty.
So how are they accomplishing
those kinds of planning
and where are some situations
where active inference
might be able to step into those settings
and potentially do better
now? I
think that's a really good question.
And so frame for you to jump in
if I missed something.
But so within the oral setting,
from what I know,
if they are considering temporal
horizon is greater than one,
then they have hierarchical RL
or they have options
where they're considering trajectories
that are greater than one
that allow them
to consider a whole sequence of play
before they like that's rolled out.
If they select a particular policy
instead of like that one single action
to statement thing.
But I'm not I haven't really worked
with options that much though.
Do you know?
Yes. So options are like one way to
achieve this kind of multistep sort of
like I guess oversize,
almost like this inductive bias, right?
That you will like your choices
will be kind of contiguous blocks of
like more than one step,
whereas a kind of policy kind of it's
just like I'm going to take one step
and then I'll have this kind of
next stay resistance.
But I think
what's important to disambiguate
is actually you can do sort of planning
in the model style things
because you can view active inference
as a sort of model based like
in the kind of RL paradigm.
And indeed, like within model based,
you can have
like planning methods similar to
what is done in active inference.
However, I guess like the key distinction
here is when you do planning in model
based on real,
you simply just trying to type.
You tend to take some sort of suit
like kind of mini
evolutionary method, usually
something like the cross entropy method.
And what you're doing
is this kind of search overall actions
that you take at a certain point in time
that maximizes your kind of reward over
say a horizon of say 20 steps
and you can do some clever stuff, you can
terminate with a Q value function.
But fundamentally, like
it doesn't take you away from this sort
of definitional difference, which is in
active inference, you're doing this
sort of planning over actions,
even though they might seem superficially
similar, like kind of basically
like drawing lots of actions and seeing
which ones maximize some sort of utility.
In the case of active inference,
or the useful kind of information
and the desiderata about like exploration
and exploitation
are wrapped up in that maximization.
Whereas in all it's
kind of it's a bit harder to understand
like in the classical sense,
we're just trying to maximize reward.
But you can have heuristics
where you say, oh, but maybe
I want to also maximize
some notion of model uncertainty.
And it kind of gets a bit
more difficult to
naturally integrate
all these approaches into the same thing
because like in the example of factoring,
because everything's a distribution,
you just get a higher priority.
Or if you want to integrate it out,
if you don't want to deal with
kind of tuning it.
So yeah, that's kind of where I feel like
there is this kind of difference
cool.
And what kinds of settings
do you think that those types of, of
action as inference and planning,
as inference could be utilized,
like what kind of data sets or questions
or contexts are people currently
using another type of method?
But then you're excited
to see active inference play a role.
I think most of the open
ended problems where you don't really
have a reward function, I think
because the
way the the oral agent is learning
how to interact with
the environment
is through a reward function.
So anything
where you don't really have that,
where you have an environment
that is changing.
But I know that there's like
a whole host of people
within the oral community
working on intrinsic motivation
or internal motivation.
So those sort of things do overlap
with the activities
discrimination
but particular paradigms.
I think for me the more interesting
aspect of active inference
comes from the fact
when you start thinking about
biological agents
and if you're modeling a patient
or someone with schizophrenia,
you can with this Bayesian framework
you can change the priors
to try and see
how the person is interacting,
where I guess it's
the it could be that their policy,
like the way they're following
the policies, are broken or just could be
are the parts that are different.
But I think within the oral setting,
if you are stepping outside the
the standard the game,
right, so like Majic or Jim environments
and start getting into ones
which are more open ended
and you don't have any rewards, then
active inference
could be potentially useful, but
I'm a little bit hesitant
to just say whether it will be better
because if you start augmenting
Bayesian zero
with all sorts of interesting
components, then
to a certain extent it will be active
inference scaled up
which
which is potentially a contentious point.
But I think it depends on
exactly what you are incorporating
and that's why for this particular
presentation and our work,
we were quite careful in defining what
reinforcement learning meant,
which is that you have to have
this reward function in play
and you want to maximize
this reward function.
And then if you include into that,
our framework has to have that.
But like the objective has to be that.
But if you
if you sort of bypass
them, say, OK, I'm just going to add
in all sorts of interesting components
to make the algorithm or the way
the agent interacts with the environment.
I I guess
as similar to an active inference
framework or perhaps even better,
then you get that fine distinction
between
what RL is better
or where active inference is better.
Sort of it's not really bad for me
because I think both communities
from my perspective are working
similar things,
which is sequential decision making.
And with our work, it's mostly
with sequential decision
making in the face of uncertainty,
whereas some of our work might our work
might not be focused on that.
So I think it's
when you start drawing the boundaries,
it becomes a little bit hazy
where like things are separate or not.
And I think I went off
on a little tangent
but so do you want to add anything
to that in terms of the environments
and the paradigms that might be useful?
Yeah, I think
if one of your aims is that you're given
an environment
that you just have no prior knowledge
about how you ought to behave,
you could argue that you could deploy
an oral agent that uses
some sort of curiosity or epistemic
uncertainty reduction mechanism.
But I mean, I know there is like
a tiny bit of work about learning priors
over reward functions and learning those,
but I'm not hugely aware.
But I think what's important
to understand is in the limit of like
exploring the entire environment,
your epistemic uncertainty
is going to go to zero, right?
Like you, you will observe it everything.
And then it's unclear
what your relationship
is going to do at that point, especially.
So you have a deep neural network.
That parameter dramatizes
how you take actions.
Whereas in the case, and I think what
this paper was really interesting
for me to see when we run these
experiments was actually has put a prior
over your preferences and eventually
you learn a mode of behavior.
It may not be optimal,
but your agent eventually learns to adopt
the behavior that is self-fulfilling
because it reduces epistemic uncertainty.
And then all that's left is says, well,
I think these are kind
of useful behaviors,
or at least these are behaviors
for me to do in the world.
And eventually you get
quite repetitive behavior and it might be
a more kind of accurate simulation
of in the absence of any information
like how something intelligent
might actually behave in a world.
Whereas in the oral paradigm,
it's less clear.
You know, once
you reduce all that epistemic uncertainty
about where the value is
and you haven't found any
like what is your agent
really doing at that point?
But I think my problem at the moment
with like the actual formulation
is like this works on
like a discrete state formulation, right?
We saw really nice results
in that setting.
But I think if you scale it up,
act of inference,
agents are going to have the same issues
if you're using like advertise inference
or something to actually
approximate your likelihood
or transition functions, which means that
you might not get these nice properties
that we're seeing
at the small scale.
So scaling it up, this
is an interesting and open ended problem
at the moment.
Scaling up in the right way
that you can include
like these confusing models that we have
in the discrete state formulation.
And that's how we do
the last set of simulations
where we introduce the conjugate, tries
to do the learning over there.
The prior preference is,
but also the likelihood
so becomes a little bit hazy
how to learn like I have a hyper prior.
I've read in time your network
if you're scaling it up that way.
So that must be
a lot of work
needs to be done in that area.
And in order to actually show
those appropriate
that you can have
these interesting components
that you need to start thinking about
how you would include these hyper priors
because it is not reasonable to say
that you're going to have a hyper prime
over the the parameters space
such like the beat up hype
so that hyper pi over the gamma that that
would be sufficient in those settings,
not hyper
prior, but the way the agent,
the selecting is actions.
It has to be over that model parameters.
And if scaling up means
that you're losing that nice way
to disentangle that particular model
parameters, then becomes very uncertain
I don't know.
It's an open ended problem for me.
Yeah.
I think high dimensional problems
still represent
something that is relatively difficult
especially just due to the kind of
you know, the further we stray from base,
like the less principled it becomes.
And, you know,
it's like it's, it's quite fine line.
Very interesting
about how whether within the oral
or active inference paradigm, there's
sort of the sparse skeleton,
the bare bones at the core.
And then sometimes these other layers or
tweaks are needed and
pretty interesting to learn about.
And also what you had said earlier, nor
about how the challenge
is planning for sequential action
when you're in feedback, whether
just by moving around in environments
or your local environment changes
or you're playing a game with a board
game is going to change or you're
trading on a market sequential action
you can't just plan steps one through 100
without at least thinking about some
what ifs
and then only having access to limited
observational data and planning amidst
fundamental uncertainty.
So I think a lot of those points
of contact with the motivations
of reinforcement
learning and machine learning will maybe
bring some more light
into active inference and
push some of those frontiers
you just mentioned.
So I have a question and anyone else in
the chat can ask a question to
let's say somebody is
wanting to learn about this
and they're actually in a lucky beginners
mind perspective
because they might not have been enticed
by learning reinforcement learning,
but they've gotten curious
in active inference
and excited by your presentation.
And so what
what kinds of computer languages
or skills might they want to learn
or what kinds of approaches or mindsets
would be helpful if somebody, let's say,
weren't coming from a classical machine
learning perspective
and learning active inference,
but rather
kind of upskilling into active inference.
What would you recommend
either of you to that?
Do you want to go first with that?
Yeah, I mean,
I think it's an interesting way to view
a kind of this kind of potential person
because I kind of felt
like I was somewhat like this person
like way back
when, like when I was starting
to have conversations
about active inference some
and I like.
The. This paper started off
basically as a tutorial I was writing
and having spent two or three months
kind of in the evenings reading about
trying to like sift through the active
inference literature and I think,
you know, I think it's fair to say that
at times it's
unapologetically dense
and quite difficult to read.
So, you know,
without trying to self endorse
but I do think reading this manuscript
in particular, like the whole aim
philosophically when like when we started
writing this was to really understand
like what is what is happening here?
Like what is this kind of expected
free energy quantity?
Like why do we care about it?
So I know
from a kind of theoretical perspective,
I think this is a very lucid
presentation of the concept.
So at least you can get some sort
of intuition as to what's happening.
As for the kind of coding side,
I can't really speak to that,
but I'm sure I'm sure more kind of has
has worked it works with it quite a bit.
And I was going to say it
sort of depends on what
the primary objective of the person is.
Is it for a sort of
get an understanding of the
the high level conceptual ideas
or treat it as an algorithm?
Because if you're coming from free energy
principle, to active inference
is a different story.
Or if you if you're taking
two inferences, a siloed algorithm,
specific kind of sequential decision
making scheme, right?
So depending on that is sort of differs.
But I still will say I think this paper
definitely is really nice in the sense
like it does try and define
all the different concepts and goes
through the different combinations,
maybe not in as much detail
so with the assumptions in play,
it gives you the
the layout
of how you might be able to derive it,
but certain things like what,
what the approximate
density, even reading entails,
those are very
difficult questions
where you would have to like dove
into variational inference
literature to understand.
So I guess from that perspective,
someone who's coming into the field
should spend some time
thinking about racial inference
and how that ties
back to the active inference formulation,
because the perception part of active
inference is in most instances exactly
the same as variational inference,
which is on optimizing
the model evidence
or the maximizing the evidence around
so the
second thing that I was going to add is
that the paper with Lancelot de
Costa is really good for someone
who wants to drill down
into deriving everything themselves.
And sometimes it's super technical.
So this are the paper
that I walk through today.
The one with Phil and Tilman Co
is, is a nice introduction for someone
who is not familiar with the mathematics.
I'm just wants to get a layman's summary
whereas this the paper,
the paper with Lance's
first
author gives like the detail, derivations
and a lot of assumptions in place
so that's from like understanding
the theory part.
From the coding perspective, it entirely
depends what the end objective is.
So if someone wants to work
with discrete state formulations,
then the MATLAB code call has written
and it's yes, work with lots of
nice simulations
and examples that you can use.
And also our code is online
and you can access it.
So there's a link in the paper
in the software
section
that gives where exactly the code is
and you can look through that
and see how the simulations were done.
If someone is interested in
more, I guess,
high dimensional simulations
of active inference that
there's some recent work with
the software Zephyrus.
So it's fantastic as first author
where we've got a nice again,
we get ready before that work as well,
which gives a breakdown
of how you would implement
the simple act of inference agent using
very short 25 fighters
and a simple transition network.
So there's lots of different areas,
but for someone starting out,
they sort of
have to understand what they want
to focus on the theoretical side
or whether they want to focus
on the implementation side.
The radical side
would be drilling down into the variation
inference in the maps behind it,
and if they want to focus
on the coding aspect
and they want them to figure out
whether it's continuous or discrete state
limitations that interest interested in
and then sort of break into
is going to use them,
most of it would either be writing the
coordinates of motions
themselves or they would have to use
like some sort of like
neuro network
to approximate
that continuous distribution of interest
or the discrete state
which calls written out.
And if if they have questions
about the discrete state,
I'm happy to take emails
as well as anyone
because all the continuous states
that state space as well.
Thanks for the distinction.
And it's such a large difference
between the MATLAB code,
which we got to walk through with Ryan
Smith and Christopher White,
which is doing matrix
multiplication and such.
And then here comes the neural networks
and it's offering
sounds like new opportunities
with high dimensionality
and continuous variables,
but also a lot of new challenges.
So what is the essence that's shared
by the matrix form and by this more
machine?
Learning style?
Because for some people
it might be splitting a hair,
quite literally.
The difference between
two computer languages when they're
thinking about active inference
from a ecological psychology
or in an active philosophical
or an embodied performance
perspective, of all backgrounds
that converge on active inference.
And so to somebody outside the
the strand of hair,
what is it that we can really distill
that is core active inference?
And I wrote down a few things
so that you had said,
what are those core pieces that allow us
to dove into the matrix mode?
With MATLAB or into the neural network
mode with like Python.
And so I think it comes down to my
summary slide the way I think about it.
So the active inference,
the core ingredients are formulating
the gentle model
and here simulating the gentle model
is a privatization of the gentle model.
So you can use the discrete state
categorical distributions
or you can use a more continuous state
formulation.
And again,
the the neural networks simulation
is a specific instantiation of that.
So that would be one way of sort
of differentiating that.
The second one is the optimization
of the objective functions in play.
So in the the MATLAB code
we're doing gradient descent using mean
field message crossing algorithm.
So specific formulation that's been
introduced in a couple of cases.
And I specifically didn't
walk through that or you're doing back
propagation to actually calculate
the or lambda distributions.
And then we're just solving
those distributions that you have.
So it sort of depends
on which formulation your
and it depends on how you optimize
those objectives.
Either
you're taking the implicit forward model
or you're taking an explicit,
gentler model
and one thing I forgot to mention
is that Alex Chavez and Conor Hynes,
they've been working
on the discrete state formulation of
active inference in Python,
which might be of interest
for people who want to focus on
one specific language
that can do like the more high end
or high dimensions stuff
and the discrete state formulation
that Karl has.
I know they're also looking for people
to work on the code base,
if anyone's interested.
So it's called Infer Activity.
I think
that's on GitHub as well,
if anyone's interested
cool.
Any sort of last thoughts
or comments from either of you
and. No, I think I'm OK now.
What do you reckon.
I think we're kind of noticing a bit of a
an increase in interest
in active inference.
Like just to give you an example,
like maybe areas where
even active inference
would have been considered before,
like robotics you're now beginning
to see more and more of it.
So I think if you do want to get involved
in it, now is a particularly good time.
Great call up and I'll
just re recommend the excellent paper
that we're discussing.
It's in the description of this video.
I really appreciate both of you
for joining.
You're always welcome to
come on to be speaking about a paper
you've authored or not.
But again,
thanks a lot to Nora and Philip
and I hope to see you again
on a future active inference stream.
Thank you.
Thank you for inviting us.
So I see I've done your piece by.
Awesome
stop stream.
Great conversation.
Thanks a lot to Philip and nor really,
but to Philip.
And nor really,
but to Philip. And nor really.
But to Philip. And nor really.
But to philip. And nor really.